YOU NOTICE THEIANNIS POST-UP IN.
THE BUCKS ARE 1 FOR 11.
>> Stan: GRANT WILLIAMS GETTING.
>> Stan: THIS BOSTON DEFENSEOP,.
STEPS THROUGH AND GOES UNDER
ROBERT WILLIAMS. HE HAS CARTER.
TWO TO SHOOT.
POCKET.
HORFORD RETURNS THE FAVOR.
GRANT WILLIAMS LOOKING FOR HELP
TOP.
HE'S NOT THE LONGEST GUY IN THE
JAYLEN BROWN WITH 20.
4 FOR 4 FROM THRERE
>> Brian: TATUM'S GOT IT, KICKS.
THEY NEED TO TRY TO KEEP HORFORN
>> Stan: YOU CAN ONLY LEAD WITH
YOUR VOICE IF YOU LEAD WITH YOUR
ACTION ON THE NBA PLAYOFFS AND
THREE IN THE PLAYOFFS.
>> Brian: JAYLEWN IN THE AIR.
TATUM GETS IT BACK.
HE
AND IT'S GRANT WILLIAMS WHO
DOUBLE, PORTIS IS GOING TO HAVE
HIS WAY DOWN THERE WITH SMALLER
GUYS. THING THAT
WOULD CONCERN FINDS BROWN.
BROWN HAS NOT SHOT IT WELL IN
THE SECOND HALF.
GIVES IT RIGHT OUT.
INSTEAD OF
TATUM KICKS IT OUT TO WHITE.
BACK ON THEN.
THE SAME THING WE SAW BEFORE ON
THE KICK.